I'm not quite sure when it started. We know that President Kennedy and President Johnson...
...each used a number of pens when they signed bills.
And the clerk believes that it started with either Truman or Roosevelt.
And the practice that a president uses a number of pens...
...and then gives the pens to people who worked particularly hard on a bill,...
...who sponsored the bill, who really fought to get it done...
...or to whom the bill means a great deal.
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13,...
...14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19... No, there's one more.
This is the most pens that we've ever used.
That would be 20 pens today.
He has gotten much better at this. He, in fact, jokes about this actually.
That he is, you know, at the beginning it does not...
...come naturally to use a number of pens when you're signing your name.
And so, but he has now gotten very much in the groove.
I've gotten good at this.
And today would be interesting 'cause these are almost twice as many as he's used before.